now let's go over to wisconsin where
three middle school boys are facing
sexual harassment charges
okay middle school boys sexual
harassment
why because they quote unquote
misgendered someone
so here's the local news report let's
listen to that
i received a phone call from the
principal over at the elementary school
for warning me letting me know that i
was going to be receiving an email
with sexual harassment allegations
against my son rosemary rabidu's
13-year-old son braden is one of the
three 8th grade kiel middle school
students accused of sexual harassment
something she disputes he said he's
being allegedly charged with sexual
harassment for not using proper pronouns
i thought it wasn't real i thought this
has got to be a gag a joke
one has nothing to do with the other
according to the wisconsin institute for
law and liberty or will now defending
the accused students in march one of
their peers announced the pronouns they
prefer to be addressed as they or them
one of the alleged incidents brayden and
the others were supposedly involved in
happened in april she had been screaming
at one of braden's friends to use proper
pronouns
calling him profanity and this friend is
you know very soft-spoken and kind of
just sunk down into his chair and braden
finally came up defending him saying
he doesn't have to use proper pronouns
it's his constitutional right to not use
you can't make him say things some might
say or think that you or your son are
against the lgbtq plus community not at
all not at all my my children have been
raised to love everybody equally shortly
after finding out her son was being
investigated rosemary reached out to
will title ix sexual harassment
typically covers things like
uh rape
dating violence uh quid pro quo sexual
favors right really egregious stuff
there's nothing even remotely close to
that alleged in this case will says the
school district's policy doesn't cover
the misuse of pronouns and neither does
title nine
okay so treating uh three middle school
boys as rapists because they wouldn't
use
the pronoun that somebody wanted them to
use
so we're ruining these boys
lives
because they wouldn't use the pronoun
please i beg you get your kids out of
the public school system
just get your kids out of the system
if it's at all possible for you to do it
if there's
if there's anything that you can do
there are any other options in your life
get your kids out of the system
because this but you know wisconsin
uh
it may be a liberal area particularly
where the school where the school is i
actually don't know i don't know whether
i don't know i'm not familiar enough
with the various areas in wisconsin but
the point is this is not um
this didn't happen in san francisco
i mean i'm sure this kind of thing does
happen in san francisco board that's not
what we're talking about we're talking
about wisconsin
um so it's
they could just simply ruin your kid
kid's life
if you don't get him out of the system
and there's an important point here also
just to uh
just
just to clarify
he was punished these boys are punished
not for using incorrect pronouns
but to make it all the worse here
they're punished for using the correct
pronouns
now even if they had used incorrect
pronouns like if they just gone up to
some boy who is a boy and called it call
the the boy a girl
to call that sexual harassment is insane
obviously
but it's even worse than that because
they used correct pronouns
they said what is objectively correct
and that is sexual harassment according
to the school
and the pronouns that were preferred
here they them
like that doesn't uh what if what if uh
the the kid said that uh identified with
one of these neo pronouns
you know the neo pronouns are just the
made up gibberish
zs i have the list here of neo pronouns
zem zer
okay what if the kid had walked in and
said um i refer to me as nee nem or
nernell
what that's that doesn't i don't know if
that's those aren't words
i wouldn't even know how to use that in
a sentence because it's not a word it's
gibberish
but if the kids don't do that are they
sexual harassers now are we gonna lump
them in as rapists
um
but this just goes to show again the
point that we made at the beginning of
the show in the opening monologue
this is fear and coercion
that the gender ideologues are using
this is all they have
okay if we were to do a poll
on uh on this idea of people identifying
as they are them
i can guarantee you at least 90 of
people would think that it's ridiculous
once again no one is being convinced
of the rightness of any of this
all they have is fear and coercion
and
the good news
is that movements that rely and we've
seen we see so many historical analogs
here so many examples throughout history
and we know that movements that rely
entirely on on fear and coercion and
manipulation and force
they don't last forever
it's just it's not sustainable in the
long run now if you can actually change
people's hearts and minds
well now you have something that could
endure for generations for thousands of
years potentially but if all you have if
you're trying to force this square peg
into a round hole basically just just
just through force
it's not
it can't last forever
eventually people get tired of it
eventually people gather up the gumption
to
to stand and say no i'm not going to go
along with this
and that moment it has to be now now is
really the time it should have been
10 years ago
or before that
but it wasn't and now here we are in
this moment
and we can all decide
especially those of us and i'm sure most
people watching right now are adults so
those of us who are adults who are
grown-ups
we can decide if we're going to finally
take a stand and draw the line and say
we're done with this
we are not going along with it we are
not going to cooperate i don't care what
you do i don't care you can kick and
scream and cry you can call me whatever
name you want to call me
but we're finished
if you're a man i'm going to call you a
man and that's it
if you're a woman you're a woman and
that's it and those are the only
categories that i will recognize and
none others
you know the people in the poll the
the large preponderance who said that uh
yeah they know the truth but they don't
want to say anything
i get it i understand that you're afraid
um i understand it can be
startling and unsettling when you've got
a bunch of people screaming at you
trust me i know from experience
but if we don't draw the line right now
then then what
we're just going to pass it off to our
kids
are we just going to coast through the
rest of our lives and then turn around
to our kids and say uh well you guys got
to figure this out
because we are going to leave for you in
a completely insane society
we're all semblance of of sanity and
rationality and truth has totally
collapsed you're welcome
figure it out
no we can't do that
i mean our kids uh aren't gonna
it's too much to ask of kids
you know in the trailer we we had the uh
the one line there from scott nugent
who's someone we we interviewed in the
film um
the line
you know got me at 42
your your child doesn't stand a chance
and
that's true with the qualifier that if
you just abandon
your kids if we as collectively abandon
our kids to this madness then they don't
stand a chance
[Music]
they do stand a chance if we take a
stand and defend them
they have better than a chance in that
case
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content